- I'm going to make his life a lot easier,
and he is going to just destroy mine.
- They're probably going to be like,
oh, wow, you're not
asking me for ice cream
and you actually want
to Netflix and chill?
Okay, well, maybe they might
be a little confused by that.
- An example of an Alex Ernst tweet,
would be to say something really (beep) up
and they're like "Hey, what's up, Alex?"
- My tweets are art, alright?
- For Yuri it's been too damn long,
and it's time to get him a date.
- Cheesy pickup lines.
That's like my thing.
- I'm going to fix all your relationships.
- That would be amazing.
- I'm pretty much going to
go as hard as you go on me.
- Once I start talking (beep), I know Alex
is going to come back and do it the same.
- For him to trust me with his phone,
(laughs) it's like the worst idea ever.
- I'm scared (beep)less.
- So, I'm leaving work,
and I'm proud to say
I got Yuri a date.
- I have Eli's phone,
and I changed his profile
picture to kind of drag.
- I don't know where Yuri is,
and checked my Instagram,
he is having dinner
with some lady I've never
seen before in my life.
- (Yuri) The girls seem to
really dig the cheesy lines.
- I just told all of Alex's fans that he's
releasing a pop solo album (chuckles).
- Nobody's ever going to believe
him ever again after this.
(record scratch)
- He told all my family and
friends that I won the lottery.
That I won eight million dollars.
So everyone's like calling my phone.
- I would go on Facebook and see
what he's messaging people
and I'm like you know,
he's not doing a bad job.
- I went on his Bumble account.
All I asked was,
Netflix and chill?
And they were like, yeah, I'm down.
- I had no idea how massive
his community was, of women.
I go on Facebook Messenger,
names after names after names,
how does he keep up with all of this?
- His roommate sent him a text
to wake him up at five,
so I called him at five, and told him
I wouldn't be able to
make rent this month.
- He's texting all
night, and then I started
getting worried, and he's
just texting all night long,
so I was done after the end of the night,
I was like I want my phone back,
this is ridiculous.
- No.
(together) Absolutely not!
- No (beep) way.
- Hell, no.
- Hell, yes!
- I would never do this again,
this is my personal space,
this is like one of the few private things
I have in my life.
- It was uncomfortable, it
was strange, I felt dirty.
- It's exhausting, trying to think of ways
to ruin his life.
- Also, there are at least
like 36 guys on Tinder
that know your number, so..
(laughs)
- Hi!
- Oh, hey guys.
- Sarah! Up here.
- We made a series!
- It's coming on November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here.
- Over here.
- Right here.
- I think they've got it.
- If you look over here,
then you can see it.
It will be released 2015. November. Okay.